maybe just weighing up the risk as well
after for example
yeah
a big winning attempt
giving up this pawn for kind of again
that alpha zero type compensation
squares
but okay you can also go c4 what about
playing c4 yeah
bishop bishop g5
at least white has this kind of solid
structure now so um even if that gets a
good screen well c4 is not good so what
about h6 can he go h6
do to this reason or you just want to
take on c5 in this case uh i was
thinking maybe not g4 still
so he has played
so he's made a move after
what was it 45 minutes or
it looks like rook e8
was played
again just judging by the camera there
rookie eight
rookie eight yeah so turns out to yeah
just he does want to keep the tension
but
yeah i mean 45 minute think and then
rookie
he won't be too happy with that magnus
just knowing him he's a
perfectionist as well magnus you had a
very long thing in the opening and we
were wondering what the thing was about
did it pay off was
did you get the right ideas during that
thing i wouldn't say so because
i was i played the same move that i was
going to play after after one minute
actually i did the same i suggested
rookie eight and then uh at the end
40 minutes later we realized it was the
best yeah
oh it's a bit it's a bit strange that
this is a theoretical position
with white to move because people used
to play this line with the pawn on h3
like
yes they used to play this d6
um d6 c3 uh sorry d6 h3 and then knight
a5 and d5
um
but yeah i
realized that even the tempo of my
position is
probably not great um
what would white usually play with the
extra tempo if you didn't have time for
the piano i mean some queenie too maybe
okay we need to